the agency behind bts raised 963 billion
won thursday
marking the biggest south korean ipo
since 2017 and making founder bong shiok
south korea's newest billionaire the ipo
pushed bighit entertainment's valuation
above
9 trillion won as shares opened at 270
000 won bong who now owns just under 35
of the company has a net worth that
forbes estimates at 3.2
billion dollars the seven members of bts
all in their 20s also got a windfall
each of them are now multi-millionaires
through shares given to them earlier by
bong
thanks to the band's worldwide success
big hit is now south korea's most
profitable entertainment agency
it pulled in 63 million dollars in net
profit in 2019
more than the big three k-pop agency
incumbents sm
yg and jyp entertainment that same year
bts debuted on the forbes celebrity 100
list and became asia's highest
earning ban before taxes from 2016 to
bighit's annual revenue grew more than
fifteen hundred percent while net income
jumped eight-fold over the same period
but as live events the major revenue
driver remain at a standstill
sustaining that momentum will be
challenging in april
an analyst at hyundai motor security
slashed his earlier forecast
of 616 million dollars in revenue
to a mere 277 million dollars for the
agency this year
[Music]